wusstest du dass es in Italien aktuell
den schnellsten Zug Europas gibt und
zwar ist das der frecia Rossa 1000 Pferd
bis zu 400 km/h Leute das ist einfach
viel zu groß hier aber ich habe jetzt
die Lounge gefunden ah hier
okay
und diesen Zug bzw Einzug dieser
Baureihe habe ich letztens mal in
Italien getestet von Rom nach Mailand
bezahlt habe ich 155 € für die executive
class erste Klasse so gesehen ich hatte
extrem viel Platz und die ganze Zeit
essen ich konnte essen was ich wollte
das Essen war zwar nicht so nice aber ja
man konnte halt so viel bestellen wie
man will egal ob Wein Bier Cola Brote
Nudeln Reis für 155 Euro auf jeden Fall
sehr stabil nur ich hatte halt auch 95
Minuten Verspätung also das ist nicht
nur in Deutschland so denn